there's uh some kind of retro 70s james
bond girl going on and there's some like
kind of wait
stop the rumors that you're going to be
a bond girl is that a little hint
this isn't the work so we don't know
after playing a spy
in her toxic music video britney spears
was almost a bond girl
[Music]
that's just one of many career
bombshells brittany broke to e.t
in 2004. you know before she married
kevin fetterline and had two babies
instead i don't want to give everything
away
one surprise britney teased had to do
with a celebrity guest appearance that
was supposed to happen
during her showtime special from miami
well there's a very
special guest that's going to be there
yes
and a male female it's a male tall dark
i
worry i worship him he's not available
he's just a very he's an amazing artist
he's brilliant
he's a singer and in another interview
britney revealed she was part of a movie
that never ended up happening
but my first role that i'm supposed to
be doing it's a movie that it's called
door to door
and we're still like um you know in the
whole process of doing that that's my
next project
i'd love to do more movies i'd love to
do like three or four more movies
and then get back on the singing trail
of things
e.t was britney's go-to show as she
released her fourth album
in the zone the only difference is the
fact that i really took my time to
record and really go
you know and make it right if i wanted
to record a song in
two hours or three days it was my
schedule and just having that behind me
i don't know musically i probably
changed but as a person i think i'm
still
you know the same girl i think if you're
one to work out there's songs if you can
you know brave new girl it's such a
workout song
there's songs like um every time if you
want to have an emotional breakdown and
[Music]
cry
[Music]
and then there's um songs like uh of
course you have to have a mate with you
and like the candles
and have those special moments we were
backstage with b
as she got ready for her 2003 abc
special promoting the record
this first time i'm presenting myself
with all of my new music my favorite
songs
toxic's the first song which is going to
be very gothic and silly and touchy it's
about
being really addicted to a guy's like
he's a drug team
[Music]
then it goes into breathe on me which is
a really really um sensual song you
don't actually physically touch a guy
but it's just
the touch and the presence of him makes
you very aroused
[Applause]
[Music]
beyonce said that she's actually really
shy and that when she's on stage
and she becomes this sexual seductress
she names it she calls her sasha
are there kind of different sides of you
maybe i should be britannia
you heard it here first i like that no
i think i definitely do that when i get
around people that i don't know
i get very i'm very introverted and like
hi some issues you know
when i get on stage i'm like yeah i have
the same thing
so is there a switch that you flip on
yeah it's like
it's like when you get on stage it's
just like this different persona comes
out and you're like
if i can't take over the world and on
her 2004 onyx hotel tour
brittany planned to do just that onyx is
an actually a black stone whatever light
is reflected on it and um
in real life that's the stone changes
colors and i thought it was kind of
symbolic to what i do too whatever light
is projected on me and being an actress
that's what character you become right
and like i come i go through all these
different characters to the show
and we made it to onyx hotel because i'm
traveling right now i'm in so many
different hotels and
just a whole you know combine the whole
thing together i know this sounds really
cheesy but you have to respect yourself
and and it sounds really weird but
really don't care what people think and
go
with your instincts on what you think of
videos because actually when i came up
with a lot of the concept for the songs
and the video
a lot of people were like wow you know
we can't do this and go with it and
really believe in it and
you know just believe in yourself and i
think that's what makes you keep you
know
staying on top of the game and and
honest i love what i do
i like i love working and i you know i
love this
you very much is it grueling preparing
for a tour um it's kind of hard but um
like i said i love
i love working out and um i go through
like i'm gonna have a two weeks
rehearsal before the tour
and um i mean the dancers will have a
time the first week just kind of get to
know each other and chill and vibe with
each other and
i mean doing the promotion and stuff
overseas has kind of helped us like me
vibe with them and
get the energy feel of what we're gonna
feel when we're on stage you know
i get extremely nervous i do but right
when i get on stage and
right before it's a little annoying
because i'm like oh my god why am i so
nervous i've done this
so many times i'm a pro why am i so
nervous and then i'll get on stage
and then it goes away it's like i feel
like it's just the anticipation that
freaks me out but um it's exciting i
think it's hard
oh there's an extreme hot when you get
out there and you see
the fans and the energy it's just
overwhelmingly
cool you're so young what lessons have
you learned i have to say i chose this
for my life and i feel very
blessed i sound so deep and
philosophical but it's true i really i
feel very blessed with everything that's
around me
but i think there's ups and downs with
anything that you do you know and i
think that the way they
do um the press the media but ever since
i was 16 they
focused in on negative connotations with
me sometimes
because you're a target yeah you know
and i think you're young
you're successful exactly but um
but i just and at first when i was
really young i was just very it was kind
of cool in a way because i was very
naive and oblivious to the whole thing i
was like
i'm just doing my thing you know and
then once you get older it's like you
become a little bit more aware
and which is kind of a sad thing because
it's like oh what are they saying but
it's like sometimes i try to snap into
that um
that mode of just you know what you you
have to just live your life
you know and do what i love to do and
move on and
you know focus on you know positive
things and not let
you know stuff like that get you down
because otherwise you go crazy
what makes you happy i love to write i
love to write i'm always writing in my
journal
writing things i like to be by myself i
know i sound like a loner i like being
alone
just being with my special friends
sometimes too like a small intimate you
know
just having like little parties at the
house and watching sex in the city
together
i'm a girl who loves coffee starbucks
okay
i love to read magazines i love going to
the movies
um i don't know just normal stuff like
that
baby
[Music]
what was the concept of the video the
concept was basically i just wanted to
do something
where i could play a bunch of different
characters and play with a bunch of
different looks and
um the whole concept of me playing this
villain was just so intriguing to me i
just thought it'd be a lot of fun you
know and
to go through all these guys and
manipulate them and to be like
you know power girl you know so that's
basically the whole concept of the video
but um
i don't know i think one of the my
favorite shots is the one where i had
the red hair
i just like i was feeling that so much
just to see yourself in different looks
and stuff like that
it was it's just really it's fun what
happened what happened
to you when you were a redhead i got to
be on a bike with tyson and
um i had these crazy glasses on and it
was like a cat suit and i was
really feeling the part my manager was
like oh who was she today
i like the nookie nookie in the plains
it was a little uncomfortable
but um being you know we were there and
we just started doing it and the guy
that i was with was totally
you know we were just we're trying to
work it out was team effort you know
but um it was cool yeah but i know when
i saw the shot it looked a lot more
sexy and smooth on camera than what it
actually felt
e.t spoke to brittany one more time
before she left for her tour
i just got finished with my first like
real run through like a couple of
seconds ago and it was
really cool the flow of it is so much
fun to do
and um it's cool do you ever have a
moment where you're sitting there going
what the hell am i doing yeah how am i
going to pull this off is it that
complicated
yeah but we have one more week left of
rehearsal so i'm gonna be able to pull
it off but it's just
um this is the first tour that i'm doing
where i have it's 17
songs that i'm doing wow still it's a
really long show
is there any theme of the costumes i've
had a lot of amazing uh
cool shows with costumes and stuff this
is by far the best
costumes i've ever had it's gonna it's
cool i feel like i can't wait to put the
clothes on and just be like hi
just be on stage it's like playing dress
it's the funnest thing in the world how
many
i have actually i only have seven
there's the last four i had a 120 89.
how do you stay sane on the road believe
it or not being on stage keeps me sane
it's like my therapy
really it's like i do my therapy in
front of the world it's really weird
you